we are following germany's covet 19
crisis and chancellor angela merkel
is preparing now to take questions from
journalists on her government's covet 19
strategy let's go right to that press
conference and see if we can listen in
to the chancellor's words as she gets
started the federal press conference
we are independent we are not part of
the german government
the berlin parliament journalists
are usually here which is why these
press conferences are
organized and chaired by journalists
which is a tradition for a long time and
we're pleased
that you are here again madam chancellor
i think you are here
three times and we're pleased that you
are following that with the first
month of the year you have the floor
madam chancellor
ladies and gentlemen we
find ourselves in a very difficult phase
of the pandemic
and this was the reason why the heads of
state and government
of the federal states and the national
government
continued their deliberations on tuesday
and
didn't wait until next monday as
originally planned
and that is also the reason why i am
once again here and very happily so
i want to give you a sense of my
analysis and evaluation of the situation
and then of course respond to any
questions you may have
and i want to thank the federal press
conference for inviting me to do so
we find ourselves in a very difficult
phase of the pandemic
and why is that the case because
we have a bit of a fractured image on
the one hand we're seeing
the daily number of infections declining
finally that's the good news and there
are fewer people
on our intensive care wards
than there were around christmas and
before christmas
this is good news as well because since
the beginning of the pandemic
it has always been about not exceeding
the response capacity
of our public health systems it's not
just a medical question
i've said this often enough but i'll
repeat it again
it's not health or business health or
education health or culture they're not
a contradiction in terms
exceeding the response capacity of the
public health system
serves the people it serves business
culture
the economy everything
and we cannot imagine often enough
what would happen if we were to wait
with the measures
to tighten them up or if we had waited
in the past until our icus were over
filled that would have been too late and
this is why
it is very necessary and very
encouraging
that the current situation is easing a
bit
that shows that the tough measures that
people in germany have had to live
under for weeks now are starting to pay
off
and it shows that it's worth the effort
and i can only once again
most cordially thank all of the efforts
of the people in this country
for pulling together we know that this
virus is very hard for all of us to bear
but i said at the beginning that there
was a sort of a fractured image
and that was the good news on the other
hand we're also seeing
seeing shockingly high levels of
mortalities
today again over 1 000 people dead
these aren't just numbers these are
people who died alone
these are people's lives these are
families grieving
and this is something we need to bear in
mind again and again and above and
beyond that
one of the things we're struggling with
at the moment is that all of the efforts
we are putting into place to contain
the virus cannot exclude
one real risk and this risk is something
we can see more clearly now than we
could at the beginning of the year
and that is the mutation of the virus
particularly in britain
and in ireland but also in denmark and
the netherlands
and we have cases of it here as well
based on what we know so far the
mutant strain of the virus is
considerably more contagious
than the one we've been living with for
the last year
and that this is the main
reason for the new shocking rise in
cases
in ireland and britain this
mutant strain has been detected here in
germany but it is not
dominant and all the same
we must take the serious
threat from this virus very very
seriously
i cannot stress this strongly enough we
need to slow down the spread of this
mutant virus
we mustn't wait until this virus flares
up here and is reflected in
explosively new rises of cases then it
would be too late
to have an even stronger wave of the
pandemic probably a stronger one than
we've seen so far we can still prevent
it
and this is why our consultations with
the state premiers
the day before yesterday focused on this
there's still
a little bit of time to try
to prevent the danger that this new
strain of the virus
means so it's about precautionary
measures and this is why
the national government and the state
governments have
decided on tighter measures to bring
down
the cases the case load that we have
here in germany
before the mutant strain of the virus
spreads even further
this evening at the video conference of
the heads of state and government of the
european union
this mutant virus mutant strain will be
a focus we'll be talking about this
mutant strain
we'll be talking about how we can ensure
that we have similar measures in place
across the european union to combat the
spread of the virus
because in epidemiological terms as the
european union we are
one area we'll also be talking about
sequencing to get a clear
overview of the mutant strain of the
virus
it will also be the subject will also be
vaccines and other aspects of this
we are therefore taking precautionary
measures for our country
precautionary measures for the health of
the people in this country
and therefore automatically
it's a precaution for our business for
our culture for environment
because if we see explosively high
spreads
of the infection this will
overwhelm our hospitals everything we
are doing to put it another way
is aimed at containing containing the
pandemic and overcoming it
so i'll stop at this point and respond
hopefully to your questions thank you
very much there are plenty of
questions many people in the room
have asked for the floor so i'm already
having to
warn people that we're not going to be
able to ask and answer every question
because
as in every press conference here for
reasons
of the virus we are limiting ourselves
to one hour
after that we'll have to stop because at
this press conference we want to
sit people down as far apart from one
another as possible
so for the
reasons of the pandemic i'd like to ask
you to keep your masks on when you ask
your questions
mr felitov is also going to be
asking some questions that we have as
well
and let me remind you that the rule is
one question and
possibly one question of clarification
afterwards mr loser
missed mr lange mr
mcmahon mr where are you
mr langer actually we'll start with you
since you're further away from the mic
i've got a question for you
we sorry this there's a technical
problem we can't hear this question very
much
but essentially it's about the
discussion that was just
had between the government and the
regions
i think that the decisions that we have
made have always been on the basis
of consensus obviously you know it's not
the case that it's the national
government and the federal state
governments that is
not appropriate there are many different
views among the different state premiers
and we
find a balanced agreement i very much
appreciate
these discussions that we have even if
they take a lot of time and they are
quite laborious but because we arrive at
agreements that everyone can support and
i think that's what the people in this
country expect from us
if there's sometimes a bit of
frustration among
the people in germany then that's
because we sometimes do not speak with
one voice
and i would like us to do that as much
as possible which is why it is important
to have these negotiations
and many of the things that we agree
still have to be implemented in the
federal states you know we're a federal
country and i appreciate this
cooperation even if it isn't
always necessarily simple but that's
part and
part and parcel of policymaking in the
coalition
agreement meetings that we have it's not
always that easy or
inter-ministerial coordination isn't
that easy either it's just part of the
job
okay if you're just uh joining us
chancellor merkel there's been speaking
uh here in berlin on the coveted 19
crisis in germany
answering a question there about her
government's approach and germany has
extended its lockdown until february
14th
it's introduced some new tougher
measures like more working from home
also medical grade masks in shops and
public transit
and we heard the chancellor there say
that it's a difficult phase still
even though infection rates are starting
to drop in germany
well our political correspondent jared
reed has been listening in to the
chancellor's words
with us hi jared it's good to see you
tell us more about what the chancellor
had to say
about the state of the pandemic right
now and also her government's approach
well as you say angela merkel repeated
that
we are in a difficult phase of the
pandemic right now and she said that
there is a
sort of fractured image where it's
encouraging that there are fewer people
in intensive care and that the seven day
infection rates are uh dropping and that
all this hard work is starting to pay
off as as she said but
there is the other side the shockingly
high level
uh of of people dying every day i mean
today for example we had over a thousand
deaths
uh over 20 000 infections these
consistently
high infection levels that aren't uh
really significantly dropping
and uh she's saying that there is a real
risk
of uh these mutations of the virus that
are seen
in the uk and south africa and uh there
are
also reports of one uh from brazil what
this could mean
for all the hard work that has led up to
this point and she and she doesn't want
all of that hard work to uh have been in
vain
basically saying that she wants to
prevent these strains
that have we've seen isolated cases in
germany but to prevent these strains
from
becoming dominant here did she give any
indication jared about where the
situation goes from here whether the
german government's considering
extending the lock down even further or
whether there's a light really at the
end of the tunnel
well she she didn't really say that but
she did talk a lot about these uh
negotiations between the federal
government and the states which have
been quite uh laborious and what
what she has found a little bit
difficult is she has sort of advocated
for the go
tough go early approach i guess she's
seen
this in all this coming but she's met
with resistance from the states who have
been
worried about the economic impacts of
tough measures on their economies also
the
social and psychological impacts
particularly on schools but what angela
merkel said that is
she there are many different views she
appreciates these views but she would
like
um german leaders to
speak more with one voice going forward
certainly there's been some criticism
over the vaccine rollout here in germany
did she discuss that and tell us a bit
about why this vaccine rollout has been
slow i think that's
that's to come in terms of uh the the
reporter's questions but what we
what we do know about the vaccine
rollout is that it has simply
been hampered uh by a lack of production
capacity and what we've heard from
authorities in the last week is that
when uh more
start to get produced then more people
will be able uh
to be vaccinated and uh unfortunately
there is a bit of um
hold up in production from the vaccine
being developed by
pfizer and by on tech but what we know
is that
around 1.2 just under 1.2 million people
in germany have received at least uh one
of the vaccines so far and then
generally
you have more than one maybe two
vaccinations and around i think
just under 50 000 have received um
the second vaccination so obviously
still
a very very long way to go in terms of
the roll out
in the meantime there certainly is a
continuation of the lockdown and
restrictions
is the german public still behind these
restrictions
largely yes a recent polling has shown
that
around 40 percent are happy with
stricter measures
around 20 would have liked them to have
stayed as they were before
they were extended by a month but around
a third
are really hoping for the light at the
end of the tunnel they they want
uh restrictions to be eased or end
completely but if we're looking at the
overall picture
largely yes support for restrictions
has been uh consistently high
i guess what the the problem has been is
that there has been
um quite uh there's been restrictions on
people's
what people are allowed to do in private
and that has not really
happened uh on the workplace so at the
moment you know you're only allowed to
meet with one other person from another
household but
generally can still go to work where
there could be an office full of people
what the government wants to do with
these new
crackdown or these new tightening of the
measures is
to uh encourage employers to allow their
employees to work from home more so that
the
infection risk at the office and on
public transport in commuting
is is significantly reduced and jared we
heard the chancellor touch on this but
she will be holding a video conference
with eu leaders later today
um also on the covet 19 crisis tell us
what's on the agenda there
that's right as angela merkel has said
she's very very worried about these uh
mutations these variant strains of uh
covert 19 and
whether they could spread across the
continent
one big topic that's going to be
discussed in this online conference with
eu leaders is the issue of
border closures and uh what we know from
the german government is that it would
uh prefer
not to have to close borders to
neighbouring countries but it isn't
ruling it out
and so if neighboring countries aren't
able to
to get infection levels under control
then the german government isn't
ruling out having to uh close borders to
uh
to to those neighboring countries though
it is saying it would
rather not have to do that it would
rather that the the entire block come up
with a coordinated strategy in order to
uh to keep infection levels down and
reduce even further uh as as the
pandemic progresses
all right our political correspondent
jared reed covering the story for us as
the chancellor
answers questions on her government's
covet 19 strategy
jared thank you so much
the number of daily coronavirus cases
here in germany
shows no sign of decreasing either in
the last 24 hours
more than 20 000 new infections have
been recorded and more than a thousand
people
have died chancellor angela merkel is
expected to hold a news conference today
concerning new measures
aimed at curbing the virus ahead of that
dw's mikaela kufner caught up with
michael's chief of staff helga brown and
with me now is angela merkel's chief of
staff helga brown
on thursday eu leaders will be gathering
virtually
to discuss the next steps in beating
corona
will border closures and more border
controls be on the agenda there
that's where uh
in the end that would be the worst way
to go
because what is it we're trying to
achieve we want to bring down the
numbers
in germany we want our health
authorities to regain control
over the chains of transmission and then
we want to reopen
that is exactly what made us successful
last year
after the lockdown we had incidence
rates of two
three four five a lot of people forget
that
now there are people who are saying they
can't believe it's possible to get the
infection rate below 50.
i believe it is possible i believe that
with the measures we're now taking
we can do it and then we will need to
defend that success
we need to make sure that it can be
sustained that in conjunction with the
effects of spring in the vaccine
this allows us to return to normality
and that we don't face renewed problems
especially through a highly infectious
virus mutation that is even harder to
control
i believe we all want to avoid that and
that's why stricter immigration measures
when a neighbouring region has become a
host to mutation simply can't be avoided
now the united states has been following
a america first policy also when it
comes to vaccinations that goes back to
a presidential order from the 8th of
december
it makes sure that every american has to
be offered vaccination before
any of these vaccines leave the country
so what will your request be on this
issue
to the newly inaugurated president joe
biden
european commission is currently in
talks with the companies involved
and if that helps us find a solution
then of course we will discuss that with
the us administration
there's no question about that now the
world health organization is criticizing
that it's the rich countries who are
getting access to vaccines
first what are you doing for poorer
countries
just as we ordered the vaccine through
the european union
so too we are taking part in a joint
initiative together with the european
union
the european commission will address
this topic
how to provide the vaccine to
third-party states especially poorer
countries
will be atop at the european council on
thursday
including the question of how we can
still do more
beyond this kovacs initiative
chief of staff for german chancellor
angela marco thank you very much
here's a quick look at some other
developments in the global pandemic
china plans to impose strict coveted
testing requirements during the lunar
new year holiday season
when millions of people are expected to
travel the country is battling the worst
wave of
new infections since last march the
netherlands will ban flights from the uk
south africa and south america beginning
saturday for a month
the country is also set to debate a
nationwide curfew aiming
aimed at curbing infections and
australia has recorded a fourth day of
zero cases this comes a day before new
rules
go into effect requiring international
visitors to test negative for
coronavirus within
72 hours before departure